what up space cowboy goes in here for
anime uproar and today we are going to
be talking about the fairy king himself
Harlequin we have already done ESCA
normally otis bond and now king and it's
all because subscribers like you have
shown love for the series and left
suggestions for future fact videos in
the comments so if you love this series
and want to keep the ball rolling make
sure to smash that like button to let me
know leave suggestions for future FAQ
videos you are burning up to see in the
comments if you haven't make sure to
subscribe and this is absolutely crucial
hit that notification bell so you
actually get notified when a new video
perhaps even your suggested video comes
out follow us on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar for a crucial 7 Deadly
Sins
updates and more season 3 is just around
the corner and I promise you it will be
epic now without further ado let's jump
into the cold hard facts back number one
first off let's talk about popularity
think about King and think about all the
amazing characters in the seven deadly
sins okay now write down in the comments
where he would place in your favorite
seven deadly sins character list do this
before I reveal how he raped in the
official polls so we can get an unbiased
view of how much you love King in
relation to the other characters I'll
give you three seconds three two one
okay now I may just blow your mind
in the official popularity polls King
lived up to his name
if we count post card and online votes
King reigned over the other characters
the king of popularity got a whole 120
1945 votes this is even more impressive
when you think about how bond who came
in second place got only thirty two
thousand eighty six votes now if we look
at post cards alone King got in fourth
place under Hawke bought and Mele Otis
it is quite possible that King fans took
advantage of the online voting system
and voted way more than once however
it's still impressive that King had such
diehard fans even from the beginning
the latest popularity poll actually took
place in 2019 so this year since the
first poll way more characters were
introduced including Eska norm so there
was way more competition however King
nonetheless managed to place in second
place only being beaten out by our Opie
protagonist Mellie Otis himself so yeah
King has king of rock levels of
popularity to match his new hairstyle
fact number two for this fact let's talk
about fairies fairies are absolutely
fascinating and I've said it before that
they have the best gig out of all of the
different races in the seven deadly sins
after I finish telling you about fairies
I think you'll agree that it's not even
fair how good they have it especially
compared to humans they can fly
transform their physical appearance
manipulate nature and read people's
hearts which is an ability similar to
mind-reading
if this wasn't good enough already the
average fairy lifespan is between 1,000
to 1,500 years King has it even better
than most fairies since fairy Kings have
an even larger lifespan fairies don't
age physically although they can have
different forms and they never get sick
despite King being pretty lazy fairies
actually need less sleep than humans if
all that ain't enough to make you
envious of fairies I don't know what is
but aside from all these perks there is
some other interesting trivia
information about fairies they're
unfamiliar with the concept of marriage
greed and underwear thus going commando
is the norm the an and bond can take
that information any way they like
another interesting piece of information
is that fairies are born from nature
from plants and trees King and Elaine
were born from the sacred tree who
chooses who the next fairy king will be
apparently though dairies can have kids
with humans and Giants so the sacred
tree may become a grandpa before we know
it lastly most faeries have pointy ears
but notably King and Elaine do not fact
number three for this fact let's turn to
the interesting world of Arthurian
legend the place where mecha bouzouki
pulled most of his characters from we
saw how Eska normally Otis and bond were
pulled out of our 30 and legend just as
Merlin and King Arthur were but was
fairy king Harlequin well it appears she
was based off of a legendary figure but
you have to dig a bit deeper the old
French term Perla Quinn derived from the
legendary King her law in some accounts
he was portrayed as king of the Britons
he met an unnamed dwarf king who had a
great red beer
and goats hooves the two kings make a
pact that if the dwarf king attends her
law's wedding the king of Britons will
attend the door sweating so when it's
his turn
King Halle attends a dwarf king's
wedding which lasts for three days in
the dwarf realm when king Halle and his
men returned to the human realm they
realized that some 300 years have passed
and that the Saxons had been in
possession of the kingdom for the last
200 years and driven out the native
Britons there are clear similarities
here to King and the seven deadly sins
as we know knock about changes legendary
figures a lot when he adapts them into
his story for instance Merlin didn't
look like a hot 30 year old woman Emily
Otis was not demon Prince but some
elements of the original legends still
remain in Harlequins case he too left
his kingdom for a long time and in a
sense abandoned his kingdom when it
needed him similarly during King and
IANS backstory we see that humans are
aging very quickly compared to the fairy
and giant Harlequin seems to be set
apart from the rapid aging of the human
world just like King gorilla
lastly King seems to adopt some elements
from the dwarf King - like having his
own otherworldly realm that he rules
over his reddish brown hair and his
magical qualities so even fairy king
Harlequin can be traced back to a legend
but as always NACA ba added new elements
to his story and identity and as a
result made him feel brand new fact
number four next let's turn to the data
book to find out some Harlequins biggest
and funniest secrets king's weakness is
his lack of muscles and he has a complex
about his childlike facial features what
he likes about himself is his elegance
in his old man form now let's get to the
good stuff the juicy details about him
in the egg as we saw with bought and
melly Otis they were obsessed with
Elaine and Elizabeth and King is no
exception he dreams of marrying Deanne
and his daily routine consists of
observing her it's actually his favorite
hobby what he wants most is the aunts
heart and I thought it was weird when I
saw that Melly Otis's favorite scent was
Elizabeth's body but I think King
one-upped him since his favorite scent
is the Ann's cleavage fact number five
King was born on April 1st
aka April Fool's Day the day where you
can get away with and even get praised
for
pulling pranks on people and trying to
trick them synonyms for the word
Harlequin include jester and Joker
thus Kings name goes very well with his
date of birth since both are associated
with trickery Kings powers also lend
themselves to tricking people King can
transform his physical appearance and
mislead people for instance when King
approaches bond in his true form bond
doesn't recognize him because he's used
to his older human form thus once again
I think knockabout picked a meaningful
birthday that corresponds well with the
character in question fact number 6 for
this fact let's look at the height and
weight specifications for King's fairy
form and for his human form in his fairy
form King has one of the smallest
characters in the groom so it's funny
that he fell in love with the N who is
the biggest King is 160 centimeters or 5
foot 3 inches tall that actually is
taller than Mellie Otis who is 152
centimeters or 5 feet tall so King is
not the shortest in the group but to say
that the 30-foot tall Deanne towers over
him would be an understatement in his
fairy form
he weighs 48 kilograms or 106 pounds
making him the lightest scent even the
shorter Mellie Otis is actually heavier
than him at 50 kilograms or 110 pounds
in his human form King is 180
centimeters or 5 foot 11 inches tall and
weighs 120 kilograms or 265 pounds in
anime reality King could probably pick
any measurements he'd like because of
his fairy powers fact number 7 next up
we're going to look at the information
we got from the special King Indian
guide book to learn even more about
their relationship Diann is not
assertive with King like she was with
Mellie Otis because she would get too
embarrassed
luckily for King daeun actually likes it
when he watches over her she loves King
no matter what form he is in Deanne
would like to get girly clothes from
King if you didn't know King creates
clothing including his own Andi and
another thing you should know is that
the N is scared of bugs
so when King finally gets wings they
look scary to her but even as she's
scared she still loves King fact number
8 in the original Japanese King is
voiced by the 40 year old Jun Fukuyama
Jun has voice acted in many
me including some of my absolute
favorites he voiced solution code geass
the most popular anime character
according to my anime list and Kraft
Lawrence in spice and wolf he Ian voiced
Roy from the Super Smash Bros games fact
number 9 in the English dub King is
voiced by the 28 year old max Mittleman
he also has some awesome roles under his
belt like Saitama from one punch man and
Kira Yamato from Mobile Suit Gundam Seed
I strongly recommend you check out both
of these anime if you haven't already
and throwing code geass and spice and
wolf while you're at it
fact number 10 as usual in lieu of one
fact fact number 10 will be a lightning
round of sorts where I give as many
facts about King as I can in a
relatively short period of time
cue the countdown three two one less Jam
King special ability is sleeping huddled
a fitting ability for the grizzly set of
sloth Kings favorite food is cheese and
his favorite animal is none in
particular his unruly hair is considered
to be his charm point and interestingly
enough the person he respects most is
the previous fairy king Dahlia a
character we haven't seen yet a person
he doesn't want to make an enemy of is
esken or and I don't blame him for that
Kings blood type is a B and even though
he looks like one of the youngest sins
he's over 1,300 years old fairy king
Harlequin the grisly sin of sloth has
gone by quite a few names and titles
over the course of the series including
lord King Harlequin the traitor and my
personal favorite old fart lastly every
fairy has a distinct smell associate
with a flower or herb King smells like
gold as manthis and that is it for
today's video thank you so much for
watching if you did enjoy this video
make sure to smash that like button to
let me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell so YouTube
actually notifies you when a new video
comes out don't forget to vote for the
next fact video by leave me a comment
below follow us on Twitter and Instagram
at enemy upper for crucial some daily
sends updates including updates about
the new upcoming anime a big thank you
goes out to our patrons over on patreon
who helped make videos like this one
possible I especially want to thank our
pro hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
king zelgius and angel Cruz and are the
one tier patrons though
stana top all clans baby ray a 17 FFT P
Steven and Rada a Lola not M Maddy Mac
239 Lakota [ __ ] and Keylong and the
patrons who transcend greatness itself
Regan Harrison and Lord Knutson or the
chosen few who have been acknowledged by
Lord we go himself if you enjoy our work
you can support it by going over to
patreon common mail for and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these kings and queens right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin
if you're interested and until next time
see ya space cowboy
[Music]